hello lovely people I'm Alana and
welcome to my Channel today we're
talking about episode eight of The Last
of Us I usually do a like podcasty type
discussion with different people every
week we're not going to do that for this
episode because if you don't know I do a
podcast every week with Troy Baker and I
imagine that we will just spend the
whole of that separate podcast talking
about the show uh that'll go up on
Friday so we'll just talk to Troy about
it instead of doing a separate episode I
also feel weird doing this at all a
little bit um where I've been giving
impressions of every episode because
Troy is a good friend of mine and so
much of this episode is me being very
proud of Troy because I think he did a
fantastic job throwing who doesn't know
he plays James
um so I was like how am I even gonna
talk about this episode because they
don't know how to separate myself from
seeing Troy and thinking he did such a
good job so I'll do my best but thought
I would give that disclaimer to start
with so this episode of course set in um
a very iconic part of the game being
David's cult and I felt like what this
episode needed to do to set up what's
going to happen next episode I didn't
know if they'd be able to do it and I am
in the camp that they nailed it I think
this episode is very very important in
terms of setting up Joel and Ellie's
relationship and how much they care
about each other everything we see Ellie
desperately doing for Joel here
completely believable and then Joel at
the end obviously unbelievably to be
honest fighting back for her so that
they are now much much closer and have
more sort of personal responsibility for
one another than they did previously
which leads us to the finale and the
decision that Joel is going to make
still feels very soon like really soon
like it feels like the show should be
way longer I can't believe there's only
one episode left but I do think they
covered a lot of important ground for
Ellie's character and the relationship
between those two characters in this
particular episode so not unlike other
episodes this episode is again about
humanity and the bad people and what
they do which is uh common in Zombie
themes or zombie shows who was still fun
to watch here especially because
David is such a particular kind of
creepy at first you know he's unsettling
the way he he takes the glove and he
slaps the girl he's talking about
bearing her dad and he's like but you
already have a father
um and then his interactions with Ellie
why does he want to preserve her don't
really make any sense
um until they sort of touch hands at the
end and I I read it um in the show and
in the game though I don't know that
it's that explicitly laid out here
as David being a cannibal pedophile
which is quite a combo quite a monstrous
man and it's made even more disturbing
by the fact that you know there's the
reveal that he used to be a teacher as
well
um he is a very potent kind of
disgusting and so I think seeing what
Ellie ends up doing to him in the end
which is obviously very violent
is something that I wasn't uncomfortable
seeing um perspective is all on her of
course and she obviously finds it
traumatic but for her like foray into
the most extreme violence we've seen her
commit I feel like they nailed exactly
how that goes down and why it has to be
David and the desperation of her
situation regarding Joel I also thought
the conversation
um about the cordyceps and and how he
kind of respects it was super
interesting because we rarely actually
hear any kind of human take on the virus
in the show not outside of the part of
her early episode episode two I think it
was that um featured the bit about
Jakarta a little bit in Jakarta rather
otherwise we don't really get a lot of
human input on how they feel about this
virus that they're living with and uh I
don't remember if that was in the game
um like I said I have been playing
through the game every week on Twitch to
line up with the episodes so I'll catch
up pretty soon because I haven't played
it since it first came out there are
things I remember really distinctly some
things I don't remember so well I don't
remember if he has that conversation
about quarter steps so I thought that
was
super interesting and yeah I liked his
character a lot very very creepy
unsettling needed for everything that we
had to cover at this point and I think
something about um
you know it's sort of Diner burning down
in the snow when she's in the warmth of
shelter and in theory could have chosen
to stay there
um and have
food and some shelter
in exchange for dealing with David is uh
a very interesting decision and I think
that the exploration of that theme with
David is something that I have touched
on repeatedly which is
um there's something about about Ellie
that again I've mentioned this a number
of times over the last several weeks
about the way that young girls tend to
respond to men they don't know and that
is very very very different to how Ellie
interacts with Joel if I were an Ellie's
situation the context of being a yonko
which I was many a year ago I would be
very polite and meek and cautious
um if I were willing to go on a journey
with him alone at all Ellie is not like
that and I wonder if
because of the way the qz works and
because of her fedger training and
because of the fact that they live in
the areas they live in it seems very
unrealistic to me but this is the way
that I'm choosing to frame it is that
maybe that was her first encounter with
somebody who would effectively be a
sexual predator that perhaps before this
Ellie had just never actually met
somebody who behaved that way and so
thus wasn't aware that they could and
she's effectively seeing a different
side of Joel's coin Joel is painted
repeatedly and this is being a really
bad guy which I'm not seeing that much
but that you know violent past Etc
he certainly kills people to get where
he needs to go and that's a very
different kind of bad guy to a power
hungry cannibal
pedophile in terms of Joel's violence
here it's one of the first times we
really see it act out
um the way he treats the two men who are
hostages is a pretty big leap into the
next episode of us realizing that he
really will do anything for Ellie and
disregard people in order to do so but
previously we'd only heard that kind of
notion spoken about but not seen so I
thought that that was really well placed
where it was also a really interesting
um
in terms of the set here the last time
we'd seen a community that was loving it
was the little communist commune that is
Jackson where this time we were seeing
very cold
very dictatorship cult-like
community in the winter
just seems like the perfect poetic right
thing to do to burn it to the ground and
across the board once again really
beautifully shot feels a lot like a
western
um which I think worked really well with
um Troy's character as well it's so
funny how sometimes he really just
sounded like game Joel I feel like I
appreciated that it definitely stands
out though but yeah once again
excellently shot incredible production
value across the board love the music
the tone even things like the color
grading
um
beautifully well made shift so I will
say that um I did definitely miss in
this episode which again keeps happening
because I have the reference point the
part where David and Ellie uh fighting
of hordes together and so you see them
Bond as well and you see Ellie kind of
get taken advantage of um in the game or
at least that's how I pictured it
effectively no infected in this episode
I definitely missed that scene but I
also completely understand why it was
cut I was looking forward to that one
and and
how complex that made that mirror
relationship with Ellie and David and
and Ellie and Joel um a little bit like
it was missing here but again I don't
know if it's just that I have the
expectation and so I can't help but make
the comparisons and I do think overall
the show is doing a really good job of
like it cuts certain things and it adds
certain things back in in ways that make
a lot of sense it feels very fresh which
is awesome we don't know exactly what
we're going to get and I much prefer
that than it'd be a one-to-one remake
and I feel like they nailed the thing
that they had to nail really which was
making sure that Ellie hits her absolute
darkest moment and showing how much
these two characters would do for each
other is the most important thing and
this was a great uh glimpse of that
definitely still feels to me uh like
where we're at right now in terms of
being just one episode left is too fast
and I would have liked another couple of
episodes I think for Joel and Ellie's
relationship because it doesn't feel
like it's made a ton of progress again
did Big leaps in this particular episode
in a way that I think was natural and
handled really well the desperation it
all makes sense the incredibly dark
backdrop of what's happening here or
makes sense but I just yeah I just feel
like it's um
just feels too short it just feels too
short and I guess we'll see how I feel
about that next week but now I still
just keep feeling like things are moving
along or real quick and otherwise again
heading into just one more episode I
think the lack of infected is a little
bit of a funnel would have liked to have
seen them slightly more often um in ways
that are used to develop the characters
of course like with David and Ellie I
think that would have been
um nice to see but hey it's a very
different shot I think seeing David and
what he does also
um made me retroactively question
Kathleen a little bit more the
kathleenoc was my least favorite in the
show so far and they didn't really feel
like had a significant payoff I wasn't a
huge fan of everything that happened
with Kathleen by the end and I think
having Kathleen early and having that
like evil sort of cultish leader just to
have a second one who in theory should
have been more important
um felt a little bit odd to me I think I
definitely prefer David uh and would
have had preferred probably two episodes
to focus on David then two episodes to
focus on Kathleen personally though of
course I loved everything that happened
with Henry and Sam with that is all I
have to say this week it's a weird one
to do again because I thought Troy was
so fantastic I loved his character I
thought he did a good job so I was just
like so enthusiastic to watch him um
that it feels weird to even like try and
remove him from the way I'm talking
about this which I'm doing my best at um
I thought he was wonderful and we'll
talk about it more on Friday but it's
also because again it's it's you know
one week before the finale it's just uh
kind of hard to say this episode had to
do a lot of work and it's hard to to
even really talk about it without seeing
the next one so I'm very excited for
next week I wish we had a little bit
more time with the show but maybe
that'll all be out the window next week
close also very glad that the rabbit
lived thank you